what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to get low by little john
and the east side boys before i start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification bell that
way you're going to be notified of my
daily videos also please subscribe i
know i said it already but please
subscribe
like
i'm moving to england there's been a lot
of unexpected costs
i'm not asking for donations but just
just a subscribe button since you're
here okay but this is for real a
national anthem and i've never seen the
music video so i'm excited
hey
all y'all scribbles y'all
369w5
[Music]
okay so what he's saying
is he's saying to the window right and
then to the wall to the sweat drip down
my balls
all what is it all these [ __ ] crawl
i think it's crawl yeah so he's just
like you know
no matter where the female is he's
getting the female
he's got it he's got like the juice like
that whatever it is
[Music]
okay one it looks like he's in a barber
shop so this haircut has gotten out of
control
out of control but now he's just asking
the girl like can i get in your pants
basically she seems into it i think
she's down
with me and we all like to see tigger
bills so bring yourself over here girl
and let me see you again know if you
want this dude now take it to the floor
but if you want to act what you can keep
yourself where you're at three six nine
[Applause]
[Music]
you know it's interesting because it's
like a sausage fest with like three
girls
you would think it'd be the other way
around i'm just saying
[Music]
you get low you scared you scared
okay so he's saying
like to the ladies let's see how low you
can get we really want to see you shake
the booty
[Music]
now
oh there's a boxing match this came out
of left field a boxing match in water
oh the females oh wow
[Music]
do the sweat drop down
i got what i got
touch your toes
i kind of like the baggy style i kind of
wish they brought this back
[Music]
[Applause]
wait is it not to the swept drop down my
balls oh my god
i did i think it was that for my whole
childhood
okay rating this song
clearly this song is gonna be a five out
of five it's a national anthem
i can't give it anything else it's a
five out of five but let me know what
you think in the comments don't forget
to subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next